he is none other than the quarterback
of the seattle seahawks 2-0 getting set
to welcome in the
dallas cowboys for week number three a
monster game
and his monster game has got as i
mentioned the seahawks
on a winning start to the 2020 season
good to see you russell wilson how you
doing russ
rich man it's always a pleasure to uh to
join you how you doing man i am doing
fine how is uh fatherhood twice over
let's start with that
it is such a blessing man just we got we
have future sienna and win
and they're they're they're all loving
each other so it's it's amazing how fast
you know you have kids it's amazing how
fast they grow i mean
every day i come home from practice i
get home around seven or seven thirty or
so and every time i i
come home from practice it feels like
he's grown another inch or two
i bet i bet and just you know uh times
two
i mean i guess now it's it's um it's
it's a it's a i guess
man of man pretty much right now right
he's exactly you know there's no zone
coverage
necessary right now i mean but i guess
everybody that works here sierra
sierra's kicking butt still doing work
and still doing everything i don't know
how she does it all i
i thought i had busy days she she's
she's doing business she's she's
she's also she's also got so much other
things going on and then
been carrying the baby and doing all
this stuff she's amazing
well that's great uh i guess let's get
let's get right down to brass tacks of
what's going on talk about amazing your
start has been amazing
the conversation of you as the uh
clubhouse leader with uh
much more course to go uh as the mvp of
the
of the nfl i'm sure you've heard that
conversation what do you think of when
you hear that
russell i mean listen i i think for for
me a lot more season ago i think you
said it exactly right and
you know my expectations to try to be
the best in the world when i step on the
field
and and try to do what i do best and and
try to facilitate the ball the right guy
at the right time and we got so many
guys catching the ball and doing things
so special and
chris carson's running to run the ball
well carlos hyde's doing his thing and
it's just been it's been a lot of fun
doing with these guys and it's not about
me it's just about
this team and what we're doing and how
we're doing it and you know they're
allowing me to look halfway decent out
there and
it's pretty fun well i mean is the
offense any
different because it sure looks it it
sure looks like
um in past years where it would be uh
difficult for you to get to a manageable
third down
or difficult for you to grind out um
and it seems it's coming easier that's
just
the eye test i'm wondering you know i
just think that we had such a tremendous
offseason rich i mean
we really spent so much time on all the
intricacies of the game and making sure
that
i spent you know an hour with the
rookies you know before our meetings you
know yeah these scheduled meetings or
whatever so we spent an hour with them
before
an hour after with the rookies and also
the vets and we just spent so much time
on ball
and uh that was that was really huge for
us despite everything going on the
outside
which has been a heavy off season in
itself and then we came here and
in week one i mean meaning practice like
day one like we were ready like we were
dialed in at night i think part of that
was some of the guys i've played with
before guys like tyler chris carson
and those kind of guys but then also
we've had great professionals come in
meaning guys like you know greg olsen i
spent one-on-one time with him guys like
phil through set one-on-one time with
him
guys like carlos hyde has played some
tremendous football over the past couple
of years and
some of the things he's done and so it
was it was effortless in that sense that
we
i shouldn't say effortless we spent a
lot of time but what i mean by that is
it felt effortless in the sense that man
we know what we're doing how we're doing
and i think coach shot he's done a
tremendous
job calling the plays we're dialed in as
a group and listen it's just the start
that's the one thing i know about this
game is you want to start strong you
want to start
at the highest level i definitely
believe that and you also want to
accelerate through
and we want to be able to accelerate
through and the only way to do that is
consistency
to stay hungry to stay focused to stay
dialed in just stay engaged with one
another
in terms of everything that we're doing
everything that we're that we're helping
each other on and
and just uh just trying to be the best
in the world you know that's the bottom
line well it's interesting russell that
you say that the off season was
something
something that was so helpful to
actually get on the same page when
when uh actual play was coming because
the conversation is that there was no
work there was no uh ability to get on
the same page
give me an example again of what you
were talking about about how
the fact that things are more fluid
because you had that
non-field time you know well
interestingly enough like there's two
ways to look at things rich in
life at any time you know and you know
the realities of our world
what they've been for the past five six
months has been um
very difficult for so many and for all
of us really in so many different ways
and when i say that i guess what i mean
by that is is that
you can either you know learn how to
adjust or not adjust
and we learned how to adjust very
quickly with how we were going to do
football
life takes some time you know you know
what i mean sometimes that those those
things
take some time but became football like
this is what we want to be this is who
we want to look like this is what we
want to sound like this is
you know the this is how we want to play
and we want to play championship
football we went away at all and so
really there was only one option and one
option is to
to try to figure out the best way to to
process to learn to
to do everything the right way to be at
the highest level professionally i think
like i said we have
such great professionals guys like
dwayne brown and greg olsen
and uh even the young guys even guy like
dk metcalf he's a
he's a you got all pro mindset he's got
all pro type ability and
it's been fun and i think that
ultimately i think more anything else
is that guys came prepared healthy ready
to play and that's been a big part of it
too as well and
um you know we spent a lot of time on
this whole thing and we
love the journey of it all well in terms
of the journey so far uh russell wilson
here on the rich eisen show
i you know we're all talking about the
stats from week one and obviously
the ones you put up personally to me
that was the most impressive week one
when you had to go
from seattle to atlanta in a pandemic
and you want to talk about not knowing
what to expect
or what you could possibly recognize out
of something
that's not ever been attempted before
what was that like
for your team to go all the way across
the country to start week one
um yeah in the middle you know you know
for me
you know i've done it a lot you know and
some of these guys guys like bobby
wagoner and i and kj we've done it a lot
you know
our whole careers you know kj's in his
10th year which is amazing and
i was like bobby we're in our ninth
years you know and so we've had to go
across country and
i don't mind the long trips you know you
get to kind of settle in
on the plane and you might pull up my
playbook and just study and just take
tons of notes and watch all the film
over and over and over again during that
time period too so it's
a little bit relaxing in a way but this
season was a little bit different
this season game one even though we had
to go on the road and everything else
into atlanta
there's so much going on emotionally for
so many people obviously okay
how's this gonna work you know like in
our normal routines have completely
changed you know and
for people who like to be consistent
like myself you know things have changed
in that way like so how do we how do we
adjust in that sense
and then two is like you know when you
when you get there
you know you have to spread out you
can't really be
near each other and talk and talk ball
and really do all the things that you're
used to doing and the way you do it i
think
you can't normally like on a saturday i
like to go get some lunch or do
something just
you know guys like to go see the city or
whatever it may be those things that
change but
more importantly i think that you know
the two things
the most the two main things is that
nobody in the stands
it's a very odd thing right so how do we
play with that and i think for me i was
used to it i played a lot of my league
ball and
you know i've been to places where
you're trying to play professionally
really it can't matter who's in the
stands or what you've batted before or
what the situation is it's this play
this pitch at this moment
and that's what i've i've always
understood but i think for a lot of guys
even guys coming from college this is
new like
guys coming from you know different
schools and lsu for example
d lew naming lewis he's used to a
national championship 100 000 people in
the stands
right there and the last thing i would
say that was different is
and not different but just the process
of it all was really more so you know
rich is
is what's been going on in america the
pandemic first of all
you know as also with everything going
on socially in america
and it's been an emotional time for all
of us and
with all of that going on you know i
remember the last time i was on a
football field
we got the pro bowl and you know i
remember being in the locker room
praying you know before the game and
right before the prayer
you know how to pray for the team the
squad and everything else
and you know the kobe situation happens
and so it's been pretty heavy
for all of us and i know for me it's
been a tough you know journey along the
way just
emotionally just thinking about all the
things that people have had to go
through and
and um just you know we had a baby
during pandemic so that was interesting
though you know so you know i'm used to
my family coming the games and so
that's been different but you know i
think we've we've accepted the challenge
that hey
you know we want to be the best in the
world how do we do this and how do we
all you know
uh take a deep breath and uh you know be
like water
and adjust to it all i know and then now
uh
obviously that that huge sunday night uh
game that was really and again i i'm
just talking about
sitting at home and watching it right i
mean you're used to the 12's going
absolutely crazy
and um and and it's empty
but i'm still into it big time and
part of it is because i'm watching you
and your colleagues in the nfl
into it like there are 80 000 fans there
and that game was just dynamite man it
was just a dynamite game
watching you and cam at the top of your
games and these defenses
you know obviously the offenses were
were putting up points but there were
still some hard hits going on and there
were still some
plays being made um and then you know
i just don't talk about the football
gods here you are on third and short
against new england all you need is that
one yard to wrap the game up
and you put you you put it up in the air
was there at any point in time as you're
sitting there like
you know i can't believe that i'm in
this situation one more time obviously
the stakes are a little different but
did that come up to you and i
you listen man i i've experienced it all
you know i think that uh
you know for me um you know we you know
i
you know for me during the past time
every time you play the patriots it's
always an interesting game and it rich
like
it's like it's unbelievable my rookie
year we came back and we
beat them uh at home it was amazing
match up i think we're down by 13 or
something like that
um obviously the super game was a super
bowl game we were up by i don't know
however much in that game 10 for 14
something like that and then they came
back
late and uh that was a tough game and
obviously that moment
you know i for me after that game that
game in particular you're referring to i
think
i think that's that game you're talking
about yeah that situation i should say
you know for me i i i learned how to
move on
you know and sure you know i i wouldn't
be where i am today in terms of
you know the past you know several years
really to be honest with you
without having a clear vision of who i
am what i am what i want to be and how i
want to do things and
the professionalism that you want to
play with and how you want to you know
just
you know work for everything and just
keep keep going you know and so for me
that's just been my mindset you know i
got no fear you know for me i've always
learned
uh you know the only the only way the
only way to make the shot is to take the
shot you know the only way to hit the
ball is they swing the bat you know the
only way to throw a touchdown to throw
it and
only way to do things and you know so i
that's just kind of been
who i am and just kind of our mentality
the whole time i think
uh that was amazing game though i mean
that matchup
i mean first of all i was excited to see
cam back playing football again such an
amazing football player what he's been
able to do over the years we've had some
amazing battles just me and him
just going back for the past nine years
we've gone after it and shut up you know
back and forth back and forth and so um
you know there's there's 10 black
quarterbacks things starting that day
which is amazing in itself too and just
think about when i came to nfl what what
the nfl looked like and now where it is
today and just
things are changing it takes time um but
things are changing i'm just
you know i'm just glad to see a guy like
cam just give him that
chance and just do his thing again i'm
glad he didn't score though
i know what i mean it really was just uh
remarkable and now obviously here comes
a big game against the dallas cowboys
for you
and as you're going through your film
study i'm sure you're seeing x y and z
right now and the whole country will be
um getting ready for this but the way
you envision the rest of the season
going out russell what would it mean
to you to win an mvp award what would it
mean to you
i know you're about mohawks you know i
know you're about the team but what what
what would it mean to you do you think
for something well i i think any time
you know
anytime anybody wants an mvp the first
thing that i think about is that means
that team is winning
right that means that team's doing a
great job of winning and doing
everything you can i think also too
you know that's my number one objective
is to be the greatest winner of all time
and try to win as many games as possible
in super bowls too and so you know that
that's
you know if i'm playing my best i think
we got a really great chance of you know
doing something special this year and i
think you know the rest of the guys too
and so
it's a team effort this game is so
special because it's such a team effort
everybody making their plays guys like
david moore making that amazing catch in
the corner and
you know tiptoeing in the sideline
moving walking into the pipeline
that was just uh you know that those are
kind of efforts and
team moments that allow players to do
special things and i think
um you know i i gotta credit my
teammates on that i think more than
anything else though
um you know for me what it means is just
that you know
all the off season work all the training
all the time that you spend all the
all the focus all the all the hours upon
hours all the
all the uh you know the flights that you
know and things that you've done
just to you know sit down one-on-one
with somebody and talk to them about you
know the game of football and
you know and just spend some quality
time with people i think that's
that's where that's where those moments
really um
show up but i think and i think that all
that hard work and all the times trying
to throw in a bucket when you're a young
kid
you know it all it all makes a
difference i think more importantly
though
is i i want to win this week you know
and take it on you know and just stay
stay focused and
and do that i know that's what it takes
to be great is to stay
in the moment stay stay neutral not to
get too high
you know i have high expectations so i
already know what those expectations are
so it's nothing new i just i just got to
stay neutral and stay in the moment
well i mean and everything going on kids
and and
uh championship aspirations your podcast
now you're you're in the podcast world
danger talk right
i'm trying to get like you rich i'm
trying to get dangerous
it's blowing up it's it's great you know
if you guys are listening to rich you
guys gotta
subscribe to my podcast it's called
danger talk it's pretty amazing it's uh
we've had shaq first of all the first
episode so season one
episode one with shaq talking about uh
you know obviously his nba career
talking about kobe his relationship with
that which was
very emotional amazing conversation with
him
about that just talking about football
his love for the game and he's played
tight end
then we had john david washington
episode two uh talking about his new
moving tenant and just
all the amazing things that he's been
able to do his dad's legacy
and how he wanted to create his own
identity uh he's just such an amazing
actor obviously from the from the show
ballers too as well
so he's a star-studded guy and then we
just uh
yesterday i just recorded with randy
moss talking about his rookie season
uh 17 touchdowns 23 touchdowns i believe
it was in 2010 with the patriots and
just
how bill belichick cussed him out and
him and tom brady during a two-minute
drill in practice and just
uh you know just how bill and always
challenged him to be the best version of
them
and so you guys got to listen to it it's
amazing uh richard you get the chance
you got to listen to danger talk you can
subscribe to it on apple and all that
and
i partnered up with espn too as well so
it's pretty cool well
look man it doesn't sound like you're
hurting for guests but if you ever need
me to to
to fill in a spot for you you've been
always great to me
russell and uh i'd love to return any
favor
possible love to have you on the show
man no seriously i know you don't have
to say that but i mean like you know i
mean you got shaq you got
john david washington he was on last
week i i told him the story about how
uh in 2006 i'm sitting around nfl
network i get a call
saying hey uh you're gonna have a
special guest if you wouldn't mind
taking care of him tonight during the
preseason to watch pre-season games he's
coming to watch his son
play for the saint louis rams because he
can't get the game at home i'm like
he said it's denzel washington what
it was john david trying to make the
rams he got in on the
in the fourth quarter of a pre-season
game and i'm like
telling him that story and just his his
journey is amazing
his story it is it really is and uh you
know his mom
uh john david talked about you know his
mom pauletta too as well and all the
things that she
she meant to him so you know i i would
love for you to obviously be on on the
podcast man it would be an honor to have
you we have uh
chris paul coming on next week so make
sure you guys we got randy moss uh
actually just just aired just just
released it i think like 50 minutes ago
okay so you guys can check it out
subscribe and then we also uh next week
i believe it's chris paul
so it's gonna be it's gonna be fun we
gotta start listening you're one of
those star-studded guys
i'll take it russ thank you for being
honored hey man thanks for coming on
last quick one before i let you go
please tell me somebody
in your team you're the russell wilson
team
is working on a cooking show called let
rosco
this this right this is this is
happening right where you're i think
somebody's working on a cookbook
somewhere i don't know i don't know
where
it is i don't know who it is but
somebody on our team is uh internally
working on cookbooks
it's made for it let russ cook like this
is what you're doing so
it's got to happen yeah well rich it's
it's always an honor man thanks for
having me on the show man always a blast
and thank you can't wait to go on danger
talk sometime
you've got a danger talk again with
russell wilson and then uh danger russ
wilson will be against the dallas
cowboys later this week
danger russ wilson is how you can also
follow him on
social media thanks for coming on
russell thanks rich i'll talk to you
soon but that's it that's right
on the rich eisen show hey you watched
all the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here